the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
alright now to start out today we're
going to finish up what we did last time
which has to do with partial fractions I
told you how to do partial fractions in
several special cases and everybody was
trying to figure out what the general
picture was but I'd like to lay that out
I'll still only do it for an example but
it will be somehow a bigger example so
that you can see what the general
pattern is partial fractions remember is
a method for breaking up so-called
rational functions which ratios of
polynomials and it shows you that you
can always integrate them that's really
the theme here and this is what's really
the bottom line and that's good because
there are a lot of integrals that don't
have formulas and these do it always
works but maybe maybe with lots of help
so maybe slowly there's a little bit of
bad news and I have to be totally honest
and tell you what all the bad news is
along with the good news the first step
which maybe I should be calling step
zero
I had it step one two and three last
time is long division that's the step
where you take your polynomial divided
by your other polynomial and you find
the quotient plus some remainder and you
do that by long division and the
quotient is easy to take the
antiderivative of because it's just a
polynomial and the key extra property
here is that the degree
the numerator now over here this
remainder is strictly less than the
degree of the denominator so that you
can do the next step
now the next step which I called step
one last time that's great imagination
it's right after step zero step one was
to factor the denominator and I'll give
you one I'm going to illustrate by
example what the what the setup is here
I don't know maybe we'll do this some
some polynomial here maybe cubed this
one alright so here I factored the
denominator that's what I called a step
one last time now here's the first piece
of bad news in reality if somebody gave
you a multiplied out degree whatever
polynomial here you would be very
hard-pressed to factor it a lot of them
are extremely difficult to factor and so
that's something you would have to give
to a machine to do and it's just
basically hard problem so obviously
we're only going to give you ones on
that you can do by hand so very low
degree examples and that's just the way
it is so this is really a hard step in
disguise in real life anyway we're just
going to take it as given and we have
this numerator which is of degree less
than the denominator so let's count up
what its degree has to be this is four
plus two plus six right so this is
degree four plus two plus six I added
that up because this is degree four this
is degree two and x squared cubed is the
sixth power so all together it's this
which is twelve and so this thing is of
degree less than or equal to degree less
than or equal to eleven all the way up
to degree eleven that's the
possibilities for the numerator here now
the part that I want to the X
information that I want to impart right
now is just this setup which I called
step two last time and the setup is this
now it's going to take us a while to do
this we have this factor here we have
another factor we have another term with
the square we have another term with the
cube and we have another term with the
fourth power so this is what's going to
happen whenever you have linear factors
you'll have a collection of terms like
this so you have four constants to take
care of now with a quadratic in the
denominator you need a linear function
in the numerator so that's if you like B
zero X plus C zero divided by this
quadratic term here okay and what I
didn't show you last time was how you
deal with higher powers of quadratic
terms all right so when you have a
quadratic term what's going to happen is
you're going to take that first factor
here just the way you did in this case
all right but then you're going to have
to do the same thing with the next power
all right now notice just as in the case
of this top row I have just a constant
here and even though I increase the
degree of the denominator
I'm not increasing the numerator it's
staying just a constant it's not linear
up here it's better than that it's it's
a it's just a constant and here is
stayed a constant and here I stayed a
constant similarly here even though I'm
increasing the degree of the denominator
I'm leaving the numerator the form of
the numerator alone it's just a linear
factor and a linear factor so that's the
key to this pattern
all right I don't have quite as jazzy a
song online all right yeah so this is so
long that it runs off the blackboard
here so let's continue it on the next
we've got this v2 X plus c2 oh sorry
B 3x plus c3 x squared plus 4 cubed all
right oh I guess I have room for it over
here
all right go I'm going to talk about
this in just a second all right so
here's the pattern now let me just do a
count of the number of unknowns we have
here the number of unknowns that we have
here is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 that
12 is no coincidence that's the degree
of the polynomial and it's the number of
unknowns that we have and it's the
number of degrees of freedom in a
polynomial of degree 11 if you have all
these free coefficients here you have
the coefficient X to the 0 X to the 1
all the way up to X to the 11th and 0
through 11 is 12 different coefficients
and so this is a very complicated system
of equations four unknowns this is 12
equations for 12 unknowns all right so
I'll get rid of this for a second so we
have twelve equations 12 unknowns so
that's the other bad news
this is machines handle this very well
but human beings have a little trouble
with 12 now the cover-up method works
very neatly and picks out this term here
but that's it so it reduces it to an 11
by 11 you'll be able to evaluate this in
no time
but that's it that's the only
simplification of our previous method we
don't we don't have a method for this so
I'm just showing you what the whole
method works like but really you'd have
to have a machine to implement this once
it gets to be any
at all yeah question oh I see this is
what was known person is just one big
equation is one of the equation but it's
a polynomial polynomial equation so
there's an equation there's an under
this function R of X is equal to a11 X
to the 11th plus a 10 X to the 10th and
these things are known right this is a
known expression here and then when you
cross multiply on the other side what
you have is well it's a 1 times if you
cancel this denominator with that you're
going to get X plus 2 cubed x squared
plus 2x plus 3 x squared plus 4 cubed
plus the term for a 2 etc it's a monster
equation and then to separate it out
into separate equations you take the
coefficient on X to the 11th X to the
10th all the way down to X to the 0
power and all told there that means that
there are a total of 12 equations right
11 through 0 is 12 equations yeah
another question should I write down the
rest of this
should you write down all this stuff
well that's a good question
so you notice I didn't write it down why
didn't I write it down because it's
incredibly long in fact you probably so
so how many pages of writing would this
take this is about a page of writing so
just think of your you're a machine how
much time do you want to spend on this
right so the answer is that you you have
to be realistic you're a human being not
a machine and so there are certain
things that you can write down and other
things you should not attempt to write
down so do not do this at home all right
that's that's the first downside to this
method it gets more and more complicated
as as time goes on the second downside I
want to point out to you is what's
what's happening with the pieces so the
pieces still need to be integrated right
we simplified this problem but we didn't
get rid of it we still have the problem
of integrating the pieces now some of
the pieces are very easy this top row
here the anti-derivatives of these you
can just write down right by advanced
guessing I'm going to skip over to the
most complicated one over here for for
one second here and what is it that
you'd have to deal with for that one
you'd have to deal with for example so
eg
for example I need to deal with the with
this guy I've got to get this
antiderivative here now this one you're
supposed to be able to know all right so
this is why I'm mentioning this because
this is this kind of ingredient is
something you already covered and what
is it well it's you do this one by
advanced guessing although you learned
it is the method of substitution you
realize that it's going to be of the
form x squared plus four to the power
negative two roughly speaking and now
we're going to fix that because if you
differ
and she ate it you get 2 X times the
minus 2 that's minus 4 times X times
this there's an X in the numerator here
so it's minus 1/4 of that will fix the
factor and here's the the answer for
that one all right so that's one that
you can do the second piece is this guy
alright this is the other piece now this
was the piece that came from b3 right
this is the one that came from b3 and
this is the one that's coming from c3
this is coming from c3 we still need to
get this one out there so c3 times that
will be the correct answer once we found
these numbers so how do we do this
how's this one integrated
trig substitution for the truth
substitution here is X is equal to 210
you or to tan theta all right and when
you do that there are a couple of
simplifications well this is I wouldn't
call this a simplification this is just
the differentiation formula DX is 2
secant squared u du u and then you have
to plug in and you're using the fact
that when you plug in the tan squared
for tan squared plus 4 you'll get a
secant squared so altogether this thing
is secant sorry 2 secant squared UD u
and then there's a 2 secant sorry for
secant squared u cubed in the
denominator so that's that's what
happens when you change variables here
and now look this keeps on going this is
not the end of the problem because what
does that simplify to that is let's see
it's 2 over 60 for the integral of
secant to the sixth power and secant
squared that's the same as cosine to the
fourth all right and now you did a trig
substitution but you still have a trig
integral all right
the trig integral now there's a method
for this the method for this is when
it's an even power you have to use the
double angle formula so that's this guy
here all right
and you're still not done you have to
square this thing out and then you'll
still get a cosine square root of 2 u
and it keeps on going so this thing goes
on for a long time but I'm not even
going to finish this but I just want to
show you the point is we're not showing
you how to do any complicated problem
we're just showing you all the little
ingredients and you have to string them
together a long long long process to get
to the final answer of one of these
questions all right so it always works
but maybe slowly by the way there's even
another horrible thing that happens
which is if you handle this guy here all
right what's the technique this is
another technique that you learned
supposedly within the last few days
completing the square so this it turns
out you have to rewrite it this way all
right
and then the evaluation is going to be
expressed in terms of I'm going to jump
to the end it's going to turn out to be
expressed in terms of this okay that's
what will eventually show up in the
formula and not only that but if you
deal with with ones involving X as well
you'll also need to to to deal with
something like log of this denominator
here all right so all of these things
will be involved now so now the last
message that I have for you is just just
this this thing is very complicated
we're certainly never going to ask you
to do it but you should just be aware
that this level of complexity we are
absolutely stuck with in this problem
and the reason why we're stuck with it
is that this is what the formulas look
like in the end if the answers look like
this the formulas have to be this
complicated if you differentiate this
you get your polynomial your ratio of
polynomials if you differentiate this
you get some ratio of polynomials these
are the things that come up when you
take anti derivatives of those rational
functions so we're just stuck with these
guys and so don't let it get to you too
much I mean it's not so bad in fact
there are computer programs that will do
this for you any time you want and you
just have to be not intimidated by them
they're like other functions
okay that's that's it for the comments
general comments on partial fractions
now we're going to change subjects to
our last technique this is one more
technical thing to get you familiar with
functions and this technique is called
integration by parts please just because
it's name sort of sounds like partial
fractions don't think it's the same
thing it's totally different it's it's
not the same this one is called
integration by parts now unlike the
previous case where I couldn't actually
justify to you that the linear algebra
always works I claimed it worked but I
wasn't able to prove it that's a
complicated theorem which I'm not able
to do in this class here I can explain
to you what's going on with integration
by parts it's just the fundamental
theorem of calculus if you like coupled
with the product formula sort of unwound
and read in Reverse and here's how that
works if you take the product of two
functions and you differentiate them
then we know that the product rule says
that this is u prime V Plus UV Prime and
now I'm just going to rearrange this in
the following way I'm going to solve for
u V prime that is this term here so what
is this term it's this other term UV the
quantity prime minus the the other piece
alright so I just rewrote this equation
and now I'm going to integrate it so
here's the formula the integral of the
left-hand side is equal to the integral
of the right hand side well when I
integrate a derivative I get back the
function itself that's the fundamental
theorem
so this is it sorry I've missed the DX
which is important I apologize
let's put that in there okay so this is
the integration by parts formula I'm
going to write it one more time
with the limits stuck in it's also
written this way when you have a
definite integral just the same formula
written twice all right now I'm going to
show you how it works
on a few examples and I have to give you
a flavor for how it works but but it'll
it'll it'll grow as we get more and more
experience the first example that I'm
going to take is one that looks
intractable on the face of it which is
the integral of log X DX it looks like
there's sort of nothing we can do with
this we don't know what the solution is
however I claim that if we fit it into
this form we can figure out what the
integral is relatively easily by some
little magic of cancellation that
happens the idea is the following if I
consider this function to be U then
what's going to appear on the other side
in the integrated form is the function u
prime which is so if you like U is log X
so u prime is 1 over X now 1 over X is a
more manageable function than log X what
we're using is that when we
differentiate the function it's getting
nicer it's getting more tractable for us
in order for this to fit into this
pattern however I need a function V so
what in the world am I going to put here
for V the answer is well dxis is almost
the right answer the answer turns out to
be X and the reason is that that makes V
Prime one okay that makes V prime one so
that means that this is U but it's also
UV prime which was what I had on the
left hand side all right so it's both U
and UV Prime so this is the set up and
now all I'm going to do is read off what
the formula says what it says is this is
equal to u times V so U is this and V is
that so it's X log X minus so that again
this is UV except in the other order V U
and then I'm integrating and what do I
have to integrate u prime times V so
look up there you prime times V with a
minus sign here u prime is 1 over X and
V is X so it's 1 over X that's U Prime
and here is X that's V DX now that one
is easy to integrate because 1 over x
times X is 1 and the integral of 1 DX is
X plus C if you like alright so the
antiderivative of 1 is X and so here's
our answer our answer is that this is X
log X minus X plus
I'm going to do two more slightly more
complicated examples and then really the
main thing is to get yourself used to
this method and there's no one way of
doing that just practice makes perfect
and so we'll we'll just do a few more
examples and illustrate them the second
example that I'm going to use is the
integral of log x squared DX and this is
just slightly more recalcitrant namely
I'm going to let u be log X the quantity
squared and again V is equal to X so
that matches up here that is V Primus is
1 so this is this is U times V Prime
right so this thing is is u times V
Prime
and then we'll just see what happens now
the game that we get is that when I
differentiate the logarithm squared I'm
going to get something simpler it's not
going to win us the whole battle but it
will get us started so here we get u
Prime and that's 2 log x times 1 over X
applying the chain rule and so the
formula is that this is X log X the
quantity squared minus the integral of
well it's u prime x times V right that's
what I have to put over here so u prime
is 2 log X times 1 over X and V is X and
so now you notice something interesting
happening here so let me just demarcate
this a little bit and let you see what
it is that I'm doing here
so notice this is the same integral so
well here we have X log x squared we've
already solved that that part
but now notice that the one over X and
the X cancels so we're back to the
previous case we didn't win all the way
but actually we reduced ourselves to
this integral to the integral of log X
which we already know though here I can
copy that down that's minus 2 times X
log X minus X and then I have to throw
in a constant C and that's the end of
the problem here that's it alright so
this piece I got from example 1 now this
illustrates a principle which is a
little bit more complicated than just
the one of integration by parts which is
a sort of a general principle which I'll
call my example 3 which is something
which is called a reduction formula a
reduction formula is a case where we
apply some rule and we figure out one of
these integrals in terms of something
else which is a little bit simpler and
eventually we'll get down to the end but
it may take us n steps from the from the
beginning so the example is the natural
log of n to the X to the N power DX and
the claim is that if I do what I did in
example 2 to this case I'll get a
simpler one which will involve the n
minus first power and that way I can get
all the way back down to the final
answer so here's here's what happens we
take you as log log X to the nth power
this is the same discussion as before B
is X and then u prime is n times log X
to the N minus 1 times 1 over X and V
prime is 1 and so the setup is similar
we have here X
times log X to the nth power minus the
integral on there's n times it turns out
to be log X to the N minus 1 and then
there's a 1 over X and an X which cancel
all right so I'm going to explain it's
also abstractly a little bit just it
just to show you what's happening here
if you if you use the notation FN of X
is the integral of log X to the nth
power DX and we're going to forget the
constant here then the relationship that
we have here is that FN of X is equal to
n log I'm sorry X log X to the N that's
the first term over here minus n times
the preceding one this one here and the
idea is that eventually we can get down
if we if we have we start with the nth
one we have a formula that includes so
the reduction is to the n minus first
then we can reduce to the n minus second
and so on until we reduce to the 1 the
first one and then in fact we can even
go down to the 0th one right so this is
the idea of a reduction formula and let
me illustrate it exactly in the context
of examples one and two so the first
step would be to evaluate the first one
which is if you like log X to the zero
power DX that's very easy that's X and
then F 1 of X is equal to X log X minus
F 0 of X now that's applying this rule
so let me just put it in a in a box here
this is the method of induction
here's the rule and I'm applying it for
n equals 1 I plugged in N equals 1 here
so here I have X log X to the 1 power
minus 1 times F sub 0 of X and that's
what I put right here on the right hand
side and that's going to generate for me
the formula that I want which is X log X
minus X that's the answer to this
problem over here this was example 1
notice I dropped the constants because I
can add them in at the end so I'll put
in parentheses here plus C that's what
would happen at the end of the problem
the next step so that was example 1 and
now example 2 works more or less the
same way I'm just summarizing what I did
on that blackboard right up up here the
same thing but in much more compact
notation if I take F 2 of X that's going
to be equal to X log x squared minus
twice f 1 of X again this is box for N
equals 2 and if I plug it in what I'm
getting here is X log x squared minus
twice this this stuff here which is
which is right here X log X minus X if
you like plus C so I'll throw I'll leave
the C off okay
all right so this is how reduction
formulas work in general I'm going to
give you one more example of a reduction
formula so I guess we have to call this
example for let's speak fancy let's make
it the sign oh no no let's be fancy or
still let's make it e to the X all right
so this would also work for cosine X and
sine X the same sort of thing and and I
should mention that on your homework you
have to do it for cosine of X I decide
changed my mind on the spur of the
moment I'm not going to do it for cosine
because you have to work it out on your
homework for cosine and in a later
homework you'll even do this this case
so it's fine
you need the practice okay so how am I
going to do it this time
this is again a reduction formula and
the trick here is to pick you to be this
function here and the reason is the
following so it's very important to pick
which function is the UN which function
is the V that's the only decision you
have to make if you're going to apply
integration by parts when I pick this
function as the U the advantage that I
have is that u prime is simpler how is
it simpler it's simpler because it's one
degree down so that's making progress
for us on the other hand this function
here is going to be what I'll use for V
and if I differentiated that if I did it
the other way around and I
differentiated that I would just get the
same level of complexity differentiating
e to the X just gives you back e to the
X so that's boring it doesn't get us
make any progress in this process and so
I'm going to generate instead let V be e
to the X and up sorry this is V Prime
make it V prime is V 2 VX and then V is
e to the X at least it is
any worse when I went backwards like
that alright so now I have U and V Prime
and now I get X to the N each of the X
this again is U and this is V so it
happens that V is equal to V prime so
it's a little confusing here but this is
the one we're calling V Prime and here's
V and now minus the integral and I have
here n X to the N minus 1 and I have
here e to the X so this is u Prime and
this is V DX so this recurrence is a new
recurrence and let me summarize it here
it's saying that G n of X should be the
integral of x to the N e to the X DX
alright again I'm dropping the C and
then the then the reduction formula is
that G n of X is equal to this
expression here X to the N e to the X
minus n times G n minus 1 of X so here's
our reduction formula and to illustrate
this if I take G 0 of X if you think
about it for a second that's just
there's nothing here the antiderivative
of e to the X that's going to be e to
the X that's getting started at the real
basement here again as always zero is my
favorite number not one I always start
with the easiest one if possible and now
G 1 applying this formula is going to be
equal to X e to the X minus G 0 of X
which is just right because n is 1 and n
minus 1 is 0 and so that's just X e to
the X minus e to the X alright so this
is a very very fancy way of saying the
following fact I'll put it over on this
other board here
which is that the integral of X e to the
X DX is equal to X e to the X minus X
plus C yeah question I did this in my
the question is why is this true why is
this statement true why is G of zero
equal to e to the X I did that in my
head what I did was I first wrote down
the formula for G zero which was G zero
is equal to the integral of e to the X
DX because there's an X to the 0 power
in there which is just 1 and then I know
the antiderivative of e to the X is e to
the X ya when this method will work you
know e to the X how do you know when
this method will work the answer is only
by experience you must get practice
doing this if you look in your textbook
you'll see some some hints as to what to
do the other hint that I want to say is
that if you find that you have one
factor in your expression which when you
differentiate it it gets easier and when
you anti-differentiate the other half it
doesn't get any worse then that's when
this method has a chance of helping
alright and there is no other there's no
general thing the thing is though if you
if you do it with X to the N a DX X to
the N cosine X that's the N sine X those
are those are examples where it works
this power of the log I'll give you I'll
give you one more example here so this
was this was G 1 of X right this is this
one I'll give you one more example in a
second yeah
stay that's best bad I was thinking in
the back of my head of the following
formula which is another one which we
just we just dumped alright so these are
the types of formulas that you can get
out of integration by parts there's also
another way of getting these which I'm
not going to say anything about which is
called advanced guessing you guess in
advance what the form is you
differentiate in and you check ok that
does work too with many of these cases
alright I want to give you a a an
illustration of just because you know
these these formulas are somewhat
somewhat dry but I so I want to give you
just at least one application where
we're almost done with the idea of these
formulas and we're going to get back now
to being able to handle lots more
integrals than we could before
and what's satisfying is that now we can
get numbers out instead of being stuck
and hamstrung with only a few techniques
now we have all of the techniques of
integration that anybody has and so we
can we can do pretty much anything we
want that's possible to do so here's the
here so if you like an application that
illustrates how integration by parts can
be helpful and we're going to find the
volume of an exponential wineglass here
again don't try this at home
so let's see it's going to be this
beautiful guy here think okay so what's
it going to be this this graph is going
to be y is equal to e to the X then
we're going to rotate it around the y
axis and this level here is is the
height y equals 1 and the top let's say
is y is equal to e so that the
horizontal here coming down as x equals
1 ok now there are there are two ways to
set up this problem and so there are two
methods and this is also a good review
because of course we did this in the
last unit the two methods are horizontal
and vertical slices those are the two
ways we can do this now if we do it with
so let's let's start out with the
horizontal ones that's this shape here
and we're going like that and the
horizontal slices mean that this little
bit here is is a thickness dy and then
we're going to wrap that around so this
is going to become a disc this is the
method of disks and what's this distance
here well this place is X and so the
disk has area PI x squared and we're
going to add up the thickness of the
disks and we're going to integrate from
1 to e so here's our volume and now we
have one last little item of business
before we can evaluate this integral and
that is that we need to know the
relationship here on this curve that Y
is e to the X so that means X is natural
log of Y and in order to evaluate this
integral we have to evaluate X correctly
as a function of Y that's the integral
from 1 to e of log Y the quantity
squared times pi dy
so now you see that this is an integral
that we did calculate already and in
fact it's sitting right here except with
the variable X instead of the variable Y
so the answer which we already had is
this f2 of Y here so maybe I'll write it
that way in so this is f 2 of Y between
1 and E and now let's figure out what it
is it's written over there it's Y log Y
squared minus 2y log Y minus y the whole
thing evaluated at 1 e and that is if I
plug in e here I get e right oh except
there's a factor of Pi there sorry miss
the PI factor so there's an e here and
then I subtract off well at 1 this is e
minus e so it cancels there's nothing
left and then at 1 I get log 1 at 0 log
1 is 0 there's only one term left which
is which is 2 so it's minus 2 that's
that's the answer
all right now we get to compare that
with what happens if we do it the other
way so what's the vertical vertical so
by vertical slicing we get shells and
that starts that's in the X variable it
starts at 0 and ends at 1 and its DX and
what are the shells
well the shells are if I can draw the
picture again they start the top value
is e and the bottom value is is you know
I don't need a little bit of room for
the bottom value is is Y and then we
have 2 pi X is the circumference as we
sweep it around DX all right so here's
our ball our new volume expressed in
this different way so now I'm going to
plug in what this is it's the integral
from 0 to 1 of e minus e to the X that's
the formula for y 2 pi X DX and what you
see is that you get the integral from 0
to 1 of 2 pi e X DX that's easy right
that's just 2 pi e times 1/2 right this
this one is just an area of a triangle
by factor out the 2 pi e and then the
other piece is the integral of 2 pi X e
to the X DX from zero 1
are you asking me whether I need an x
squared here
I just evaluated the integral I didn't I
just did it geometrically I said this is
the area of a triangle
I didn't anti-differentiating evaluated
I just told you the number because it's
a definite integral all right so now
this one here I can read off from right
up here above it this is g1 all right so
this is equal to let's check it out here
so this is PI e right minus 2 pi times G
1 of X evaluated at 0 and 1 so let's
make sure that it's the same as what we
had before it's PI e minus 2 pi times
here's G 1 so it's X e to the X minus e
to the X so it x equals 1 that cancels
but at the other at the bottom end it's
e to the 0 so it's it's minus 1 here
right is that right yep so it's PI e
minus 2 it's the same yeah question
from here to here is that the question
so the the step here is just the
distributive law this is e times two pi
times X that's this term and the other
term the minus sign is outside the two
pi I factored out and the X and the e to
the X stayed inside the integral sign
all right thank you
all right the correction is that there
was a missing minus sign last time when
I integrated from zero to 1 X e to the X
DX I had X e to the X minus e to the X
evaluated at zero and one and that's
that's equal to plus 1 I was missing
this minus sign the place where it came
in was in this wineglass example we had
the integral of 2 pi X e minus e to the
X DX and that was a 2 pi e integral of X
DX from 0 to 1 minus 2 pi integral from
0 to 1 of X e to the X DX and then I
worked this out and it was 2 pi e or so
sorry pi e and then this one was minus 2
pi and what I wrote down was minus 1 but
there should have been an extra minus
sign there right so it's this the final
answer was correct but this minus sign
was missing right there all right
so just
right there all right